Please welcome Kygo.
-Hi, welcome.
-Thank you.
For exact a year ago,
you had never entered a stage.
No, that's right.
In January,
I did my first concert in Paris.
-Did you know what to do then?
-No, not really.
I've got the offer to come to Paris
for one and a half year ago.
I had to turn it down because
I didn't know how to DJ on stage.
I had never before
touch a DJ mixing console.
Your entire career has been
taking place at the Internet.
Yes, via social medias,
Facebook and SoundCloud.
That's a site for distributing music,
and then people might like or share.
I've started to make remixes,
alternative versions of known
and less known tunes.
Then people shared it
with their friends, and so on.
-But you studied something else?
-I've started economics in Edinburgh.
I really wanted to work with music,
but I heard it was so difficult.
No one is breaking through.
Lots of people do what I do.
-The two of you studied that as well?
-Yes.
What is it about studying economics,
but not wanting to work with it?
I also wondering.
At that time, I've always wondered:
"What kind of
economist job is right for me?"
"What would suit me?"
But it's a broad range of areas.
Apart from calculations,
it's about society,
and you got to know people.
Then you have to figure out
what you want to do.
How do you...
You might think I'm 80 years old now
but you remix tunes...
...that even we are familiar with.
Marvin Gaye, Dolly Parton...
What more? Coldplay...
Yes and Ed Sheeran.
I like to find older tunes
and blow a new life in to them.
I want to create modern versions.
As I did with Marvin Gaye's
"Sexual Healing".
Are you just able to take his tune
and add things to that,
or do you having...?
In that case, I've found a clip
of an acappella version at YouTube.
A clip there Marvin Gaye
sings without any instruments.
Then it was easy for me
to make my own arrangement.
Add instruments like piano, bass
and drums. Or whatever I like to add.
Are they proud of you home in Bergen?
I've get lots of positive response.
Both from family and friends.
Even from random people in the streets.
It's fun to get support from home.
When the Mayor of Bergen was told
that you would come here tonight,
she wanted to send you a greeting.
-Alright...
-... An appeal.
I would like to show it before
you leave for the stage.
-That's great to hear.
-Look at this.
Kygo means a lot for the town.
But I think that the remix
now got a bit too far.
The church bells doesn't sound
the way they used to.
The police cars don't go
"ULI ULI" anymore.
We can't keep on like this.
All sounds in our city are remixed.
There have to be just two sounds.
The original sound
and the remixed sound.
And they have to be presented
in a clear manner.
I'm quite confident that
Kygo and myself, together,
will sort out this remix-epidemic.
I am sitting here and Kygo here.
Right beside me.
That was the Major of Bergen,
Trude Drevland.
That was awesome.
I had no idea about that.
She's sitting there and waiting for you.
But first you will take the stage.
You will perform something
special for us today,
where you actually play piano.
Yes, we thought we would do
a special version today.
It's from my new single "Firestone"
featured by Conrad, an Australian singer.
Originally it's electronic with a lot
of bass, but this version is acoustic.
So It's only me at the piano,
Conrad on the vocal and a drum player.
-It will be a stripped version.
-They are waiting for you on stage.
-Thanks a lot for coming.
-Thanks for letting me.